6 24 wednesday morning i've got some
viewers chiming in on that
email about giant video screens next to
busy roads remember the other day viewer
terry was asking hey what could possibly
go wrong with a 27
600 square foot video screen on the side
of a legion stadium for folks to watch
football while they're driving by on the
freeway here's some responses like
gloria saying hey distracting drivers
with giant screens is stupid stupid
stupid
and she says isn't it bad enough they
refuse to put down their phones amen
gloria uh from julie it's ridiculous to
distract drivers more than they already
are navigation screens phones in one
hand burgers in the other we're smarter
than that vegas save lives don't be
foolish enough to put big tvs next to
our roadways what's next roadside video
games you can hotspot into
keep those responses coming buckle up
drive carefully and please put down the
phone
you can respond or if something's
driving you crazy the email address is
the same traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com